um so welcome everybody to uh this
week's session of the synthesis workshop
at the simons institute
um again we'll be continuing the theme
of
uh exploring the connections between uh
formal synthesis
and machine learning and today's session
will particularly focus on
theoretical aspects of that connection
um i'm pleased to introduce our first
speaker sushma
who's a principal scientist at sri
international
sushma has done some of the foundational
work on program synthesis and formal
synthesis
over the past 15 years uh for which
uh he was recently recognized with an xc
test of time award
um let's just dive in straight in so
smith is going to speak
about oracle guided learning of
compositional concepts
so schmidt thank you for being here take
it away
i think you're muted smith
thanks sanchet for a very kind
introduction so as sanjit mentioned i am
sushmit i am a principal scientist in
computer science lab at sri
today i am going to talk about formal
synthesis article guided learning of
compositional concepts
this is a joint work with sanjit and a
number of collaborators over several
years
i would like to acknowledge all their
contributions as well as
i would like to acknowledge my employers
intel written technologies and sri
and different funding agencies which
have enabled me to do this work of a
last decade
so what is formal synthesis formal
synthesis
is essentially a process of learning a
compositional concept
satisfying a high-level formal
specification
now examples of such compositional
concepts include programs
controllers explanations of machine
learning models
inference of intent of ai agents
and compositionality is key here because
this is what enables us to
exploit automated deduction and makes
formula synthesis
no longer just a machine learning
problem
on our last decade we have applied
formal sensors to a wide spectrum of
applications
which include program synthesis centers
of controllers
finding explanations of machine learning
models decisions
as well as inference of intents of ai
agents
we've also used it for a fun application
where we were able to automatically
generate
completely new magic card tricks
obviously we will not have time to go
over all of these applications
in 25 minutes so my plan is to go over
some
key results which i thought might be of
interest to this particular audience
so i will begin by presenting a unifying
wheel
that describes formless synthesis as
essentially an interaction between
oracle and learner both of which are
co-designed for a target concept
and this is one key differentiating
factor between formal synthesis and
machine learning where often articles
are
expected to be frozen while informal
synthesis we try to
design the learner and the oracle
together
secondly i will talk about theoretical
characterization of different formal
synthesis techniques
where we consider articles and learners
with different properties with different
powers
and then i will go over three
applications the first will be the
programs in this work which was the
first paper on
this topic that we had at xc2010 and
then i will talk about
how to use this uh method to explain ai
decisions
based on our paper in the journal of
automated engineering at 2018
and then i will talk about how to use it
to automatically generate robust control
policies
which is published in election control
2018
so what is formal synthesis and why do
we need it
if you think about induction induction
refers to
inferent general rules from specific
examples or observations
for example if we are given a bunch of
images of digits
uh as you see here we could from these
examples
infer that the rule being followed is
that all the numbers that we are going
to see are going to be greater than
equal to 7.
on the other hand deduction is about
applying general rules to derive
conclusions about specific instances
for example if we know that all the
numbers that we are going to see are
greater than equal to 7
and if somebody shows us this occluded
image that you see here
then we can infer that this number is
eight and not three
formal synthesis in contrast to
induction deduction
is about simultaneously learning from
data and deduction from rules
so if we are given a data set which has
these corrupted images
where some of these digits have been
partially uploaded and we
know that the rule that all numbers that
we are going to
see again are going to be greater than
equal to 5 holds true
then based on this data set and this
rule that we know
is going to hold true that all numbers
will be greater than equal to five
we can actually infer that the tighter
rule would be that number is greater
than equal to seven
and this is a very sort of like two
example of what formal synthesis can do
and this formula synthesis essentially a
instance of what we call cyduction
where we combine induction deduction
using structural constraints
now this example might appear very
concorded
so let me present an application which
is in a much more realistic setting but
along the same lines
here we are looking at new scenes data
set which is a standard data set in
machine learning which comprises
essentially road images from boston
and singapore what is interesting about
this data set
is that it's highly imbalanced data set
so it has a number of images of humans
cars trucks and movable objects by
movable objects you will essentially see
these road cones but it has very few
examples of
bicycles and motorcycles
and secondly many of these exam images
many of these instances
are occluded which makes this a really
challenging data set to work with
now if we apply purely machine learning
in particular deep learning
uh then the overall accuracy that we
observe is around 88 percent but
for those classes where the number of
instances is really small
the accuracy drops down to 57 and 61
further as we look at those instances
which have higher occlusion
the accuracy drops down very severely
from 57 percent to 12 percent
at 30 occlusion for bicycle and
to 2 2.36 percent for occlusion of 50
but if we use formal synthesis for
perception then
first our overall accuracy goes up
because we are able to incorporate
especially temporal rules of
co-occurrence of different
objects in our scene it goes up from 88
to 95 percent but even more
significantly
our accuracy goes up on those instances
which belong to class where the number
of examples that we had in the data set
was small
for example if you look at motorcycle it
goes from 61 percent to 73
further the improvement is even more
impressive when we look at
instances where we have occlusion so
this gives us a much more convincing
argument about why
combining learning from data and rules
for example as we do in formula
synthesis
is going to be clearly much more
advantageous compared to just doing
learning from data
now the next question would be that why
do we need it to be article guided
why can't we assume that all the rules
and symbolic specifications available to
us are directly given
and we don't need to essentially think
of it as an article we can do white box
analysis automated deduction on it
then well the first reason is that even
when symbolic specification is available
to us
it may not be amenable to deduction
two examples that uh come to mind right
away would be first
d of discussion let's say that we are
trying to use program synthesis
to de-orfuscate code now office question
can make programs
arbitrarily difficult for static
analysis and automated reduction
so thinking about the office credit code
as a white box symbolic specification
may not be quite uh workable hypothesis
to
design a technique with similarly with
neural networks
even though they are symbolically
available they are just too large to be
amenable to automated deduction
the second reason is that sometimes
the specification may not even be
available to us in a symbolic form
for example maybe we are interacting
with humans which have some notion of
what is right and wrong but they can't
put it down in a formal property
or we could be interacting with nature
or complex physical models
and these are the reasons why we are
thinking about
capturing specification not necessarily
as a white box
logical form but rather as a oracle
which is amenable to some forms of
analysis and typically lightweight
automated reduction
now to make our approach more powerful
we obviously need to design the oracle
which will be capturing the
specification
in a way that it supports particular
interfaces which are of interest to us
in some sense you can think about this
as a saying that what are the automated
reduction
questions that we can ask on this
particular
formal specification because it's no
longer available to us as a white box
but
it's rather available to us an article
and
here you will look at some examples of
what these interface queries can be
obviously positive witness queries these
are examples this is what traditionally
machine learning has been about
that given a concept give me example of
instances which satisfy this concept
which belong to this concept
the second could be negative witnesses
we are going to ask the reverse
question that give me instances which do
not belong to this concept
the third will be membership query where
you can pick an instance
and then ask an article that does this
instance belong to this
particular target concept or not the
fourth would be equivalence query
we come up with a hypothesis uh concept
and give it to the article the oracle
can either
say that yes this is a target concept or
come back to you with a count example
the next could be subsumption or subset
queries we come up with a
hypothesis concept a proposed concept
and then the oracle would come back and
say that either the target concept is a
superset of this particular proposed
concept
or give you a count example and the last
would be the distinguishing input where
the learner could come up with a concept
and the set of examples used to form
that concept and the oracle would either
find
an alternate concept which is consistent
with all these examples but differs from
the proposed concept in at least one
instance
or say that well it has no such
alternate hypothesis at which point
learner can
can be sure that this is the single
hypothesis which is consistent with all
the examples it has seen so far
now what article guided formal synthesis
does is that it takes a as
input a concept class and an oracle
interface
between the learner and the article and
again to emphasize the oracle could have
the logical specification in the data
available to us
available to it based on which it would
be able to provide responses to the
learner and then we have a notion of a
dialogue
a dialog is essentially a sequence of
query response which confirms to this
particular article interface
an oracle guided former synthesis
algorithm is
a pair of learner and article both of
which have been co-designed
where learner is going to be a
non-deterministic algorithm
that will map a dialogue to a concept
and a query
and an article is going to be another
non-deterministic algorithm
which will map a dialogue and query to a
response
we'll say that an oracle guided formal
synthesis algorithm
solves this into this problem if there
exists a dialogue
between the learner and the oracle such
that
the learner converges to the target
concept
now this can be viewed as a
generalization of
query based learning which has been
around for at least half a century
and in particular there are two lines of
work which are very relevant here
one would be the gold style learning of
formal languages which has motivated a
much
a lot of our theoretical study of formal
synthesis and the second would be
learning
from membership and equivalence queries
by
dana englund and others which has
motivated our work on program synthesis
but in contrast to query based learning
hell the oracle is not
a frozen entity which only provides
examples or
provides responses to some particular
kind of queries
but rather we have extended this notion
of oracle to support
arbitrary interfaces which allows us to
exploit domain specific advances in
automated deduction
where we can utilize knowledge from
program analysis control theory
to be able to design much more richer
oracle interfaces
than providing only examples or
responses to let's say membership
queries
so if you look at even the query based
learning
one key thing here was that they studied
the power of synthesis using different
nature of queries and that has inspired
us to look at
how we can analyze formal synthesis
techniques
and look at what is the feasibility of
synthesis when we consider
learners and articles with different
powers with different properties
in particular we have looked at learners
which are finite in infinite memory
articles which have different interfaces
the first would be that they only
support
counter examples arbitrary count
examples the second would be that they
support
minimal county examples that is they're
going to produce counter examples which
are going to be smallest in
size the third is about constant bonded
count examples
where the article is going to produce a
count example which is going to be of
length smaller than some given constant
bound b
and this is motivated by work on bonded
model checking context bonded testing
and so on
and the last one is about positive
bonded count examples
where the article is going to produce a
count example
which is going to be no larger than the
largest positive example it has seen so
far
and this is motivated by work on bug
finding methods that
mutate a correct exhibition in order to
find buggy behaviors
[Music]
now i will not go in detail about how
all of these different
articles and learners compare to each
other but just to point out some of the
highlights of our theoretical results
so what we noticed is that for both
finite and infinite memory learners
there's absolutely no benefit of using
mineral counter examples with respect to
counter examples
when it comes to looking at feasibility
of synthesis
secondly in case of finite learners what
we found is that having positive bounded
counter examples
is actually much more powerful than
using arbitrary county examples
but for infinite memory learner's case
this is not true
in fact positive bonded county examples
are strictly less powerful
than having arbitrary counter examples
further we were also able to find a
language family that can be learnt using
counter examples and minimum
counter examples but that cannot be
learned using a constant
bounded counter examples or positive
bonded count examples
both in the case of finite learner as
well as the infinite line
and our at the informatica paper has
more details about
all these comparisons we have identified
exactly what language families
belong in the intersection and union of
these different cases
uh but here i think these highlights
would probably give you a good idea of
what kind of
feasibility results we have on the
formal synthesis approaches
now moving on to some of the key
examples of
applications of what we have tried with
formal synthesis
the first one is obviously the first
paper that we wrote on this topic which
was in
2010 the xc paper on program synthesis
from components
here the concept class was programmed as
a composition of functions and
both the learning article be implemented
as a satisfaction solver in
algorithms essentially smp solvers and
the oracle interface between
both was given by the distribution input
query where the or
the learner would propose a program
which is consistent with all input
output examples seen so far
and the oracle would come back and
either provide a second program which is
consistent with all examples
or provide or say that well there's no
such a second example available
and then eventually the learner would
converse to a single
consistent program which is put to all
input output examples
and it would terminate there and say
that well this is the program that i
have synthesized
and we used it to de-office great
programs uh we also used it to generate
these bit vector manipulation programs
which even today are used often as a
benchmark in program synthesis
literature
the second example which is relatively
more recent but
four years old now uh was about
explaining ai
models in particular we wanted to look
at
arbitrary algorithms including a star
deep learning models and so on
and then be able to explain local
decisions
that is given a single decision can we
figure out why
the model made this particular decision
and if you think about it
decisions are essentially often
made on an input based on only some part
of the input some relevant part of the
input
and finding that relevant part is a key
part of the problem once you have that
relevant part of the input identified
then you can do program synthesis
decision tree learning or
even simple boolean formula learning to
be able to
characterize the explanation so here i
will focus on finding the relevant
variables
beyond that you can think of it as a
program synthesis problem
so let's say that we have a
scenario where the ai algorithm that we
are looking at is a a star
algorithm which generates plans optimal
plan
given a particular map then the learner
has a
map which is the current input and it
has ability to be able to mutate this
map in arbitrary ways
and give it to the oracle which will run
the a-star algorithm
and then evaluate some property on it
for example the property could be that
well
why does the plan have some particular
segment in it or why does it not have
some particular segment in it
and what we are trying to do is to find
an explanation for this particular
property that why this property held why
did we go through a particular segment
why did we take a particular bridge for
example
or why did we not take that particular
bridge
and we designed it essentially as a
protocol between this article and
learner and we look at more details here
but the key interface between both is
given by a simple membership query the
article can give a
map of choice where the learner can give
a map of choice and then oracle can
evaluate
the a star's output on that map and then
come back with either saying that the
property holds or does not hold
and the same can be done with deep
learning model for example let's say
that the learner is trying to explain
why a particular model which predicts
whether somebody should get loan or not
get a loan why was a particular decision
made what attributes were important for
it
and this as you can see is very
important to be able to understand let's
say biases in a deep learning model
and one key observation here is that
these machi these ai models are
often they make decisions often on very
small number of variables that is
explanations
often have a very sparse support and
this is something that we have utilized
in our work
so we implemented learn an article as
essentially
using the learner was implementing a
hamming distance
search over the inputs that is it was
finding these mutations of input
based on some hamming distance between
inputs
and the article was implemented using a
local verifier or an evaluator
and then we were able to show how we can
explain results of optimal planning
algorithms like a star
explain decisions made by reactive
exploration strategy
as well as compute saliency map of
images and more recently we have shown
that
these explanations can in fact be used
to compute confidence of a machine
learning model and detect adversarial
examples
and then similar to complexity analysis
and query based learning
or the standard teaching dimensions in
machine learning
here what we care about is the number of
queries that we make to the article
and we were able to show that even
though the overall space of possible
explanations is doubly exponential
in the total number of variables our
approach actually uses logarithmic
number of queries in the total number of
variables which makes it much more
efficient and practically usable for
even deep learning models and then i
will just quickly go over
the control synthesis part i
believe i have five minutes is that
correct
yes you have five minutes cool so
this is the last application this is
about synthesizing controllers
and here one key problem is that often
when we try to synthesize controllers
it is with respect to some surrogate
model either it's a set of
od equations or more recently these
machine learning surrogate models
but we want to deploy these controllers
in a real world
and the reason we don't try to
generate controllers either using
reinforcement learning or classical
control synthesis
directly with the plant model or the
detailed simulator is because
these are a going to be slow
uh as well as they are more resource
intensive
and they're also more risk broad imagine
trying to generate a robotics controller
by directly interacting with the
physical world
it's possible that we'll end up actually
destroying our physical hardware
so the key thing here is that well we
want to generate controller which will
work in the real world
but is designed using a physical plant
so we want to minimize the number of
interactions we have with the real world
while trying to learn these controllers
so this motivated
essentially a hierarchical oracle guided
synthesis approach where we don't have
one single
article but rather two articles the
first article is the
detailed simulator of the plant with
which we are going to have sparse
interaction hopefully sparse interaction
where we don't query this article very
often
and the second is the surrogate model
which we have to learn
as we are trying to find an optimal
controller and with
and the learner which is the controller
synthesis algorithm
can interact more frequently with the
surrogate model
i will not go in detail about the exact
interaction process between the two
but the key thing here was that we
wanted to
use max entropy as our guidance
principle to
figure out what would be the next
experiment we run
in the real world to be able to a
concurrently learn a good surrogate
model for controller synthesis task
as well as be able to design an optimal
controller
and then we used it to essentially
generate controllers for open ai gym
benchmarks
using the mujaku simulator and what we
found is that
our approach is able to achieve a higher
reverse that is
it has a much more optimal controller as
well as reach it much more quickly
that is the rate at which we are able to
learn optimal controller is also
higher than more model free
control synthesis approaches
so in conclusion formal synthesis is a
process of learning a compositional
concept
for example programs controllers or
explanations of machine learning models
and i showed you a few example
techniques that have tried to use
formula synthesis in these
contexts and then we looked at a
unifying view of formula synthesis
as an interaction protocol between
articles and learners and then
some we reviewed some key
technical results on uh feasibility of
synthesis
using different kinds of articles and
learners
so with this let me conclude uh thanks
for a patient listen
uh are there any questions
okay thank you smith um are there any
questions from the audience
radu do you have a question yeah i have
a question so
so obvious one obvious way of having an
oracle is the
model checker i think you had an example
where you
or a set solver or whatever the only
question is
you know whether this really works i
mean
so people use synthesis often because
it's
it scales much better than the
verification tool so
do you see any way of you know
avoiding this problem i couldn't quite
see the problem here
maybe let me try to eliminate your
question and get to i mean there is no
model checker for deep neural networks
right but that is essentially how can
you how can you do
if suppose i want to apply i want
because i would like to have an oracle
my
verification tool my model checker but i
cannot because
it doesn't scale up to the size of the
deep neural networks
right but that's where the that's where
the power of formal synthesis
actually comes to bear because we are
not
trying to use a predefined article it's
not that we are going to pick
some state-of-the-art model checker and
say that well this is available to us so
this is the article that we want to use
rather we are going to design article as
part of the synthesis process
so if we cannot do model checking of a
piece of code then
the oracle is not a model checker for
that code rather we are going to look at
some lightweight
analysis methods for example we could
look at methods which
do statistical sampling of inputs and
learn invariants
that could very well be a effective
article so
how do we pick the lightweight
automated deduction approach which
we can run on this class of problem is
going to determine
what oracle we use for example for
neural networks we have done work where
we try to find explanations of neural
networks here we don't need to run
a global verifier all we care about is
that can we do local robustness checks
that is available to us in fact in our
earlier work which was the nfm 2017 work
we didn't even need to do any sort of
verification
we could just evaluate the new network
model on specific examples
which is the simplest sort of queries
that you can design so
i don't think we should look at it as an
approach where we have these
predefined articles of verifiers
available and we are trying to use
those existing verification tools or
model checking tools to do synthesis
rather we are trying to figure out what
is the kind of
deductive queries that can be supported
in a given class of problems
and then design a synthesis method which
only uses that article interface which
is uh uh
which comprises using this lightweight
deduction process
does it answer your question right yeah
yeah absolutely so any any lightweight
uh tool that that is suitable uh
symbolic
and and this is the key question right
like that how do you
separate uh what is an easy deduction
question
and what you need to do solve using
induction and if you think about
the the entire technique of formal
synthesis it's trying to
essentially say that the boundary
between these two
is something that we should not
predefine this is not
that we have the best deduction approach
available out there and the best machine
learning tool available out there and we
just club them together
right it's not going to work if we take
model checkers and we take some best
deep learning algorithm and club them
together
they're not going to talk to each other
what we want to do is to think about for
a given target concept that we are
trying to synthesize or learn
what is the what is the best uh
what is the sort of like most resource
efficient
uh most effective deduction approach
that we can design for it
and then what would be the corresponding
inductive approach that we need to
design to be able to couple them
positive error
thank you very nice sure there's another
question in the q a
um from abhinav verma the question is
is there a possibility that you could
leverage machine learning techniques in
creating the oracle as well
that's a very good question i've been up
yes definitely uh i think we have worked
together
and we were looking at the problems
where we were trying to
uh design articles using machine
learning models uh what we think is the
induction and what we think that
think as deduction is not as sort of
like uh
the demarcation is not as clear as often
we think it to be
so uh definitely some deductive
approaches themselves could use
induction
and if you look at our work on
hierarchical ages uh this is one
way to get in that sort of go take a
step in the direction
that we don't think about induction and
deduction as two entities which are
talking to each other but rather this is
a recursive process
where the oracle itself could be
implemented using an oracle learner
sort of uh couple which itself could
then recurse down
um and uh so
i hope that answers your question
all right uh thanks for smith uh
perfectly
um so let's move to our next speaker
um sandra can you go ahead and share
your screen
sure thank you
okay while sandra is doing that let me
go ahead and introduce our next speaker
um